[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance in kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about at
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we are to the experts our
fantastic guest this week for the first
returning episode of season two of
trigonometry is a returning guest he's a
comedian he was a co-writer for Jonathan
pie and Rideau welcome to trigonometry
hello it's so good to have you back man
yeah it's good to be back this is fun
and you've changed the design since I
was here before
yeah we've reworked the studio yeah very
excited about it it's good it's very
sexy
thank you due to off-camera issues
normally what we do when we start off
our chats with guests is we ask him a
little bit about them you know where
they're from all the rest of it but
we've chatted before so our guests will
know and things seem to be brewing in
the comedy world at the moment most
definitely yeah would you just explain
to our viewers who might not be aware of
everything that's going on what's
happening yeah well I run a comedy night
called comedy Unleashed which is once a
month in Bethnal Green at the backyard
comedy club get the plug in right of the
time well I say Nick that's right and we
run this night in the whole point of the
night is is we felt that on the comedy
circuit at the moment there's a kind of
homogenous quality about the the the
politics that you'll get in a particular
comedy night so you know if you go along
to a standard comedy night there's not
going to be many sort of Pro brexit
comedians there's not going to be many
sort of right-wing comedians and we were
interested to set up a night where you
can have all sorts of people so we have
lots of left-wing lots of right-wing Pro
bricks at anti bricks all the rest that
we try and really get a we make a real
effort to get a breath and we and the
same goes for the audience that we're
sort of cultivating there's a real
breadth of opinion there which is really
refreshing I think but also we encourage
we say it's a free speech 9 what we
really mean by that is that we're
encouraging comics not to self-censor
right but I don't think it is true that
comics are being sent
as such I think what's happening is
culturally we're creating a situation
where comics feel they can't talk about
certain issues for fear of their career
right they they want to get on TV they
want to they want to win the awards and
if we're and if we're in this new woke
culture they won't get that far as if if
they talk about the wrong issues so
we're saying don't worry about that this
night
come along say whatever the one
experiment maybe you'll get it wrong but
just go for it and that's our that's our
point so what Witt Burt of course by
setting up this night we've been accused
of being a right-wing night okay so we
had an article in The Sunday Telegraph
came out as soon as we announced the
night and it said thank God there's a
right wing comedy night and it's run by
me and Andy Shore two lefties right but
somehow we've and most of our acts have
been left-wing simply because most
comics are left-wing right so we've but
we are trying our best to sort of
broaden it out but it's fascinating to
me that once you say the word free
speech you're branded as being on the
right it's it's a bizarre and awful
situation and I think it says a lot
about the left the left of not only have
the left failed to defend free speech of
late in the past say ten years or so but
they've actually been actively hostile
to it and that means that the only
people you get defending free speech are
these right-wing reactionary some with
some awful people and some good people
on the right as well I should say but
there are some poisonous people as well
who defend it probably for the wrong
reasons because actually people on the
far right aren't Pro free speech at all
and they can use this disingenuously
to advance their agenda and that's the
problem so then when you stand up and
let people like me when I say everyone
should have the right to say anything in
the state should have absolutely no
business in interfering with what you
say or what you think I'm branded a
fascist but there's a fundamental
incoherence that isn't there because
what I'm saying is the opposite of
fascism so what are you gonna do so
that's what's happening in the comedy
world at the moment you described woke
culture now there's one word that pisses
me off
it's a term woke [ __ ] annoying in it
and also up until recently you wouldn't
be able to use it without being ironic
you know it was it was a word that like
a couple years ago when you said woke it
was like a joke word wasn't it was it
was it was it's actually quite an old
word it goes back many decades but but
these days the way it's used at the
moment is this sort of right on culture
this sort of trendy
just yeah that sort of thing the problem
is now people are using it on ironically
and that really upsets me the the other
thing that's happening in comedy I think
at the moment is there is an attempt by
the establishment to embrace woke
culture woke culture is the
establishment so we have to be really
clear about this so we can say yes we've
got a right-wing government you know we
Americans got a right-wing president
okay so the right are in control will
actually know because in terms of
culture culturally it's actually the
woke and they're not a really leftist
but let's call them woke left sent sent
a leftist whatever you want to call them
identitarian leftists right they have
the clout culturally because it infects
everything they're in the conservative
party even you know the Conservative
Party has woke ideas right labor as well
labor who you know they'll charge an
extra ten pounds on just for anyone
who's watching this and they go away
conservative work like give us an
example of a woke idea that the
Conservatives are the gender recognition
acts and since the idea that you can you
can choose your own gender just by
making a statement and and there they
push that through okay that's that's a
woke that's awoke idea and was get it
was it was it was the Conservatives that
pushed through gay marriage we're gonna
say you know they they don't have
traditionally conservative views when it
comes to social policy so I'm saying
that these ideas and also you've got to
remember that if they say we are now
living in the cultural people will dig
up your old tweets and find things that
you've said that might have offended
someone and they will threaten your
livelihood for it and they will harass
you online for it and they'll make sure
that you you can't function in society
anymore
both the conservatives and labour are
essentially anti-free speech now they're
both Pro hate hate speech legislation
they want to be able to curb what people
say they want be able to arrest people
and they're doing nothing about the fact
that hate speech as currently defined is
based on perception so if you perceive
that someone has offended you and if you
perceive that you think that person was
motivated by prejudice then they've
committed a hate crime right so this is
not a liberal position to hold this is a
woke position to hold and it's there in
in all of the major political forces so
actually this is where the power lies
the right this this is establishment so
when we we
talk about all the time and comment
about punching up and punching down
right and I but I always in my comedy I
always punch I always punch up right
because I think satirically is more
interesting to have a go at the people
in power so when I'm having a go quote
culture which I do all the time people
say yeah you're punching down not you
but you're attacking vulnerable people
no I'm punching up very much punching up
I'm punching up because I'm attacking
the people who will who will destroy
your life if you say the wrong thing I'm
punching up at the authoritarian so you
want to police your speech who want to
to dictate and what when you can say
things and how you can say things and
what you can think and if you need
evidence that this is this is not a
major movement within the comedy
establishment let's take the last
Edinburgh Fringe Festival last year
which was opened with the speech by Nika
Burns who is the head of the Comedy
Awards where she said she was looking
forward to the new woke future of comedy
she was looking forward to the new young
comics setting the parameters of what is
acceptable and unacceptable right that's
where and that's that's the
establishment that's where by that the
awards are gonna go to what I have been
for the last few years by the way I've
been going to work actually it's not a
Gadsby another it's not about can I just
say I'm really woke you straight white
man so it's about politics now I mean
it's a way that they say someone like
Brian Logan at the Guardian who just
reviews on the basis of his politics how
much he agrees or disagrees you know
that and it you know he's not really
qualified to be a comedy critic I'm
afraid well let's unpack a little bit of
what you're talking about cuz I hear
everything is saying I personally agree
with everything that you've said I
remember hearing you talk about this
woke comedy being promoted by the
Edinburgh Fringe yeah which is the
biggest Arts Festival in the world if
you don't know and I was like oh yeah
okay whatever and then when the case
happened with me which went viral
recently I was actually attacked by a
few of these work comics online and I
went in ireia and I went and I read this
this mentor the speech yeah it was
[ __ ] horrifying it's incredible isn't
it because also she made the comparison
with the alternative comedy movement of
the 80s Yeah right now this is such a
massive misunderstanding the alternative
comedy movement was pushing against the
establishment you had the people who
were overtly racist and homophobic and
all the rest and it
and they were the mainstream and the
alternative comics are saying no we're
not doing that anymore were gonna push
against that right so they were it they
were it was Punk it was pushing against
the establishment okay I'm saying woke
is the establishment yeah it's not it's
an it is absolutely not
pushing against the establishment to be
a woke comic because you there's no risk
there it's if anything that it's
avant-garde or is pushing the arts
forward has to be has to have some sense
of personal risk about it right if
you're gonna win the awards and get all
the jobs and get on TV for saying these
things that's not Punk that is that is
the establish exactly and this is why I
bring this up because my sense having
played your night a couple of times is
that the people in the comedy world who
are now trying to do what you are doing
which is to introduce a different type
of comedy to allow people the space to
be creative to try things to be wrong
across the line you know that seems to
be to me the new Punk in the comment it
absolutely and my sense is that what
you've created and why I'm so pleased to
have been involved with and why we
wanted to have you back on the show is
that this is the start of a new movement
in comedy yeah it's a new alternative
comedy movement and and the the
reactionaries on the identitarian left
will push back and say what you were
doing is just trying to rehabilitate the
old burn of Manning style of comic I've
been told you this is a racist comedy
night we haven't had a single racist act
I wouldn't be interested I'm not going
to put a racist on stage to spout racism
it's not funny or interesting
artistically okay what we're saying is
we're we're cultivating cultivating an
audience that understand that when a
comic talks about race they're not
necessarily being racist it is to resist
this kind of literal-minded degraded
view of stand-up comedy people who don't
know what comedy is people who don't
know that you're playing with ideas
comics are often teasing those
parameters of what is acceptable and
what is not and by by delving into those
areas you are they remind us of why we
believe the things we believe yeah and
and and sometimes shock is a very
powerful comedic tool but if I'm sitting
there in an audience and I'm I hear some
stuff that is potentially treading that
line you know toeing that line of what
is acceptable if my first instinct is oh
it's obviously a bigot I'm going to
storm out whatever then then I consider
that really it's all my form of
Philistine ISM what I what our audiences
should be
learning about comedy is that oh yeah
why is that person doing this what are
they trying to achieve there and and
maybe it's a bit more satirically
interesting than you think
so I think our audience the ones that we
have now that come back month after
month are smart and they get what's
going on that good people oh not these
alt-right that's sort of white
nationalist which is what they've been
accused of being and that's the way I
think comedy should go and this is new
it's exciting it's pushing back against
the establishment and I hope they don't
catch on where do you think is gonna go
before sorry Francis what do you think
what do you see looking forward well
it's difficult because I think the
people who oppose what we're doing are
will slur would use the slur as the
usual technique and they'll call us all
try and they do all of that and they've
what we've already been doing it because
once you associate someone with that
label it means you don't have to talk to
them anymore I'm not interested
politically I'm not interested in
sitting down and debating and talking to
a fascist right because that's like
that's like trying to tell a religious
person that God doesn't exist okay
there's no there's no point you're
dealing with someone who is not being
reasonable they're not capable of debate
if you surrender reason you were no
longer capable of debate which by the
way is the major problems the
identitarian left
they have no reason therefore debating
them is pointless because they're
zealots it's a cult
so it's it's it gets very very I mean
ouch I try my best I do but but you hit
a brick wall again and again so what the
hell was I talking about I talk about
then what the night and yeah what were
you seeing okay but I think what will
happen is I think what will happen is
more and more the identitarian f will
double down and say this is pandering to
the far-right or your useful idiots for
the far right or what etc and they will
ultimately try and destroy it in that
way I'm not talking about just my night
I think I'm talking generally more
generally about anyone who tries to
react against the woke establishment
form of comedy so that will be any comic
who in there's nothing to do with me
actually is any comic who individually
tries to do that you know they'll make
sure they don't get booked though I mean
we've had comics had their employers
contacted because the things they've
said on stage and all of this is is
based on a misunderstanding of comedy
Francis I know you've been I know I've
been asking questions let me just finish
this line totally dominating yeah you
are
it's disgusting yeah you're being
marginalized yeah I've been oppressed
and marginalized by a Russian yes may I
I will I will be quiet for a while but I
just want to finish this line of
questioning because what I also see
though is let's quickly talk about what
happened with me
yeah using to sign the so ask contract
with wave Ural agreement for behavioral
agree form ferryman doesn't know I was
invited to do a gig I turned down the
contract because the contract they
offered me required me to not do any
like of the 12 isms
it said that you couldn't criticise
religion you couldn't cry to criticize
atheists because you know there's a
marginalized groups that really need
protecting and they said the old jokes
have to be respectful unkind right
so I tone it down it went viral and
here's the reason I bring it up my sense
is very strongly that the mood in the
country in the public at large is very
much with what we are doing yeah so when
you talk about this identitarian left
being opposed to Ikea that I understand
that but I think you may be exaggerating
the thread because I think the vast
majority of the public actually as the
story with me shows are totally on side
this is the problem because actually it
is a minority but it's a very vocal
minority and it's the minority with the
clout okay so these are the people who
are active online most people don't give
a [ __ ] about this stuff and they don't
get chasing people online and harassing
them but the ones that make a noise
really do and they can damage your
livelihood no they can't they have that
that power so I totally agree with you
it's not it's not many people but it's
you know it would be the same it's the
same as Silicon Valley in the tech
giant's right they have an unbelievable
amount of power about public discourse
you know the Internet and the social
media is the de facto public square now
but you have twenty or thirty people in
an office in Silicon Valley who all have
identical political leanings controlling
what is acceptable and what is not I
mean Twitter call it healthy
conversation they have a thing called
the trust and Safety Council how could
they have come up with anything more
scary as a title than that
a patron have a trust and Safety Council
this is this is a scary Stalinist stuff
and they control and they they are
seeking to control and they are doubling
down and they are kicking people off
their platforms who don't ideologically
follow their toe their line we know that
now I mean it's now become naked ly
obvious and people can say that's a
conspiracy theory no but the evidence is
in now
and and that that's the promise that
small numbers of people with the power
that's why you need to punch up at those
people and I think you're right that
most people see this as just [ __ ]
they won't even know what it means
really a lot of this stuff what woke
stuff means but you wouldn't know that
by looking on social media or the media
generally would you or the BBC you know
all the questions from now on it from
you know you carry on can I just say on
that on the behavioral agreement form I
mean a lot of the arguments I always
hear back about this is a yeah but
they're within their rights to to have a
night and say what sort of acts they
want and and I agree with that so anyway
but what they're not but then if they do
that everyone else has the right to take
the piss and criticize and say this
isn't what comedy is about and what you
know that's called free speech we both
get to do I get this all the time like
whenever I criticize someone who's
attacking free speech or something all
the time people say oh clearly what
about their free speech Jay what about
well I'm not shutting them down I'm
criticizing them or ridiculing them
that's allowed that's how it that's how
it works
this stupid myth that to criticize is is
damaging some of the free speech is
incredible but they do have a lot of
power of these people and we saw that in
particular and the thing that startled
me was how they went after the Simpsons
in particularly character of a poop yeah
and saying you know this is racist and
you know and it's disgraceful he
shouldn't be allowed to be on the show
the fascinating thing with the poo is if
you take the carrot look at the
character of Ralph Wiggum yeah Ralph
Wiggum is essentially and I'm a former
teacher Ralph Wiggum is a child with
learning difficulties yeah he's a child
who back then you would have said is
slow now we would say has global
learning delay it's quite obvious that
this you know that here's problems and
difficulties with his learning yeah
Ralph Wiggum is also probably the
funniest character in the show so if you
were going to target Ralph Lee if you're
gonna target Appu you're gonna target
Ralph Wiggum if you're gonna target
Ralph Wiggum you're also gonna say about
mr. burns he's a very old man and we're
laughing at a man who has osteoporosis
it will never end it's also that that is
a show that is comprised of stereotypes
ugly and and what's funny about that is
it's the this is an excellent example of
that literal-minded interpretation that
I'm talking about
appoo is a stereotype yes of course is
that's the joke
and it's actually the opposite of what
they think it is it's not reinforcing a
negative finishes stereotype it's it's
mocking the fact that we have them and
it's that kind of literal-minded
his inability to understand satire or
comedy you know what I think we should
introduce comedy classes into school
people understand what comedy is and
that is not literally the the actual
truth right and that's but this is also
another good example of how they do have
clout because guess what Appu is going
he's gone right if it was the case that
this is just something that I'm sort of
just some making up there's no real
issue here right why is that why is that
happen why is Kevin Hart no longer
hosting the Oscars why is this stuff
going on no they have clout really real
serious power and it's also interesting
as well like we've talked about ruff and
then but the way they seem to attack is
talk about marginalized groups but
actually bumblebee man is still in the
Simpsons and probably man i mean i'm
half Latino
I love bumblebee man but what he really
says is a word to either your Smeal in
really over the top yeah yeah you have a
president you know saying that you know
peace some immigrants from Mexico coming
in a rapist yeah there are actually
formal races to Mexicans and Latinos and
they automation because it's selective
outrage isn't it and I and it's to do
with intersectionality you know the
where'd you where'd you lie on the
grievance spectrum and is it worth
defending you and and it's it's
incredibly hypocritical as it as a
movement but that's a very good example
yeah I'm glad they're not going after
bumblebee man that's that you know
although it will get there eventually
you know they'll come for everyone yeah
you have to get over that I wanted to
touch him like I'm half and it's when
people make jokes I bring up every
episode right but the lips ignorant and
unwillingness to address what is
happening in Venezuela yeah I find in
writing to be honest with you because
it's a humanitarian catastrophe yet but
Corbin comes out says how brilliant
Venezuela is in 2012 everybody should be
like Venezuela because they can't
criticize their own side they can't what
they can't admit when socialism goes
wrong right and I don't understand
it's this is why I mean I always get
bracketed as right-wing because I
critique the left so often but of course
I could take the left's cuz I'm on the
left and I wanted to improve and I
wanted to stop [ __ ] up so that's why
I do it but they they brook no critique
at all they're not having it so
everywhere everything's got to be
perfect this is because of the leftist
mindset that believes in a utopian world
you know that's what they but they
believe they believe it if they can
control language if it control the words
that you can say they will realize this
utopia it's not going to happen you know
going to eliminate homophobia just by
saying that people comes made [ __ ]
anymore it's not how it works but they
think that they think you'll never
eliminate it by the way what you do is
you just negotiate and you find ways
through and you challenge it that's what
you do but you don't it's to do with the
mindset that's why they weren't created
criticized that's why Corbin's a saint
you know that's why they've got their
chant you know about him it's it's it's
cultish well let me ask you before I ask
this question
by the way if you're wondering why
Francis keeps mentioning that he's from
Venezuela it's because he wants you to
send them food just send food to his
house money just send me money yeah yeah
not Venezuelan money cuz that's worth
World of Warcraft money is actually
worth more than the Venezuelan current
is it really okay that is a crisis
socialism so here's the thing that I
wanted to ask you because when you talk
about you criticize that then to turn
left and you say you're on the left and
yet if I go on the internet and I put
the words Andrew Doyle it would be
right-wing reactionary blah blah blah
right here spike blah blah blah blah
blah so when you say that you are on the
Left right what do you mean by that
okay so I'm glad you roses because the
only yesterday somebody posted the thing
on Facebook calling me oh yeah it was a
podcast they call me far-right extremist
far-right extremist and a friend of mine
because I get a friend sent me this
table leadership and they sent it to me
and said listen to this it's really
funny and it says you know I listened to
the first time it's just a couple of
kids right and two years two kids they
they're not they don't know much about
politics I was probably the same at
their age I thought I knew everything
but actually didn't know anything and
that there that I turned off at the
point where like their their critique of
my politics is basically to read out the
headline
of my articles and just guess what they
might be saying you know I get this all
the time with spiked you know I had an
argument on Twitter where someone saying
I can't believe you've written another
right-wing article Reber and I said okay
specifically what argument do you have
issue with it in that and he replied I
promise he replied I haven't read it I'm
not gonna read an article in spike so
it's like what okay what's the point
most of the arguments I have with people
online are people who have just imagined
what I believe yeah right I can't do
that I can't defend a position I don't
hold simply because you as my opponent
imagine I hold that position and that's
why I'm getting tired of it like there's
no point in me debating and trying to
defend something I don't believe I can
only defend what I actually believe it's
like a futile debate so let's think back
what what makes when you talk about
blind left-wing okay so let's what does
that mean okay so if you were to write
down my core beliefs I suppose then you
then you would ask then and and you
would try and define objectively what
that is it would I would say be a
leftist so let's go so I'll go through
them if I'm for democracy and for
equality I'm for liberty right in our
democracy is an imperfect system but
it's the best that we can ever hope to
get right it's an imperfect world right
so I think we so that's why I said I am
outraged that the idea that Parliament
are effectively trying to thwart the the
referendum because it is anti-democratic
so anyway it's time for I'm for
democracy I believe in I believe in the
free market but I also think that there
should be a degree of wealth
redistribution effected through
proportionate taxation I think I see
socialism in the sort of the Joseph
Schumpeter conception of socialism as
being a corrective to capitalism as
being like to curb the worst excesses of
capitalism so by all means you've got
your ambition you know you can get
richer you know all of that stuff but
there comes a point where the the the
distinction is so egregious you know
there are people with billions and
billions of billions of pounds and they
should be taxed more I think so that
that to me I think is probably a leftist
I'm probably somewhere between socialism
social liberalism I believe in the
welfare state I believe in a National
Health Service I believe that we should
be looking
for vulnerable people in our society
that the state should have a role within
that I believe in standing up against
bigotry racism homophobia sexism
whatever challenging all of that
wherever possible I believe in freedom
of speech I believe in freedom of the
press are these things right-wing not to
me no right so what's happened and and I
always say to people women when they say
well you're on the right I'm also not
anti I'm not nationalist I don't have a
nationalist instinct in my body I don't
unpro immigration I believe immigration
is essential I'm still trying to I'm
still compute I've never voted Tory I
voted for Jeremy Corbyn if I'm a
far-right extremist I'm doing a really
bad I'm the worst far-right extremist Oh
bat better now so up and whenever I said
people tell me tell me what I've said or
what I believe that is far right or far
or right way and all they can come up
with this what I know you secretly
believe what you secretly believe is
that you're a crypto-fascist you know
you you use you're a secret racist
you're a secret bigger all this sort of
stuff well that's not good enough
there's this this telepathy you have
your ability to intuit what I actually
secretly think it's not good enough
right because guess what I know my own
mind better than you and I don't lie I
said well I don't like my arms I'd like
to get out I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
this is this bad faith interpretation
yeah that is really damaging political
discourse if I write an article
expressing my viewpoint and outlying why
I think what I think I'm not being
disingenuous that's what I think you
know it's so much easier for an opponent
to say yeah they don't really think that
though you don't really think that do
you think something else so then it's a
straw man and that's the way the
political discourse is going again and
again and I find it hugely troubling and
this is why I I'm I'm really I always go
on about a bit I'm really insistent that
I'm a former teacher I think education
is key to our intellectual development
as a nation and I think we need to
restore critical thinking into the
curriculum right when I talk critical
thinking at school it was like the DOS
subject and people weren't really taking
it seriously and I think it's key I
think first day day one you tell them
you know if you if you insult the other
person or if you mean to it their motive
if you guess what you think you've lost
the argument it's done it's over
you've lost right if
you sling insults if you call someone a
Nazi right good course I'm gonna not so
you better have some evidence for that
that's an extraordinarily horrible thing
to call someone if they're not right
reserve the term for people who are and
so I'm confused and maybe you can help
me here maybe you can explain to me how
any of these principles I've outlined
are in any way right-wing if they are
fine but does have the goalposts move
that much really I tell you what is one
thing that people could attach to you
where there you could perceive to be
right-wing okay
and it's the absolute ignorance of this
it's being pro brexit and that to
certain people then well he's obviously
against immigration he hates foreigners
therefore he's right-wing a k nazi yeah
that people bought into this narrative
that the brexit vote was was basically
yes/no are you racist and they they they
bought into this idea which was
irresponsible perpetuated by the media
and you had this thing where you know
you know after that Bracks about then
you have this this there were more hate
crimes were reported and even friends of
mine said they'd heard some idiots in
comedy clubs shouting out these overtly
bigger two things and they connected
this that people are bought into this
fantasy that we live in a really bigoted
country we don't we live in one of the
most tolerant countries in the world
right there have always been a small
minority of absolute scum idiots racists
or the rest of it and maybe it's true
that a few of them felt involved and
after the vote but the reason for that
will be that when you have the media for
six months pushing the idea that there
are sixteen seventeen point four million
racists in the country suddenly you feel
validated right there are though there
just aren't but but that if if people
been involved in that's why it's it's
not because there were 17 before million
racists right we know from the Ashcroft
polls after the after the brexit vote
that the top reason that people voted
for backs it was the principle of
sovereignty that the laws that govern
our country should be made in our
country okay immigration was important
but ever said oh no we haven't been able
to have a sensible discussion about
immigration since he knocked powers
rivers of blood speech and one of the
major I mean it was so wrong headed in
many ways but one of the major the
legacy of that is we haven't have a
conversation about it so we now have
this assumption that if you if you want
to ever if you have legitimate concerns
about immigration you were you're a
racist and people jump to that and they
that word out there the other reason
with brexit I mean I cannot reconcile
being on the left and being a socialist
with voting in favor of this massive
pro-corporate bureaucratic undemocratic
block that has a big business lobbying
relentlessly lobbying in order to have
extra regulations more regulations and
the reason for that being that it pushes
out the smaller businesses who can't
compete we have we only learnt about
their negotiations over TTIP because
they're because the it was leaked right
because everything is backdoor with them
ever and and and their unaccountable
right the European Committee we can't
vote those people out in the European
Commission we can't do it there was a
really good article on that on the BBC
about the the the extent to which laws
and regulations in this country come
from Brussels right because people say
it's a myth what are these laws what are
these laws that are not invented here
well the BBC one did a really
interesting study and it's really
difficult to pinpoint was anywhere
between 11 and 63 percent of our laws so
let's go down the middle let's say it's
like 35 percent of our laws and
regulations originate in Brussels that's
not a democratic system is it
particularly you can't vote them out so
that I cannot I cannot understand you
know if you think about the major
players in Brussels so you got younger
Barnier for hosta you know tusk
these are all center-right politicians
when you've got leftist suppose it's
socialist in our country cheering on
these people saying that these are the
bastions of freedom you're desolate
that's like cheering on Cameron or
cheering off Thatcher it doesn't make
any sense you know why do we know you
know Cameron push this the if Cameron
was the one who wanted us to remain in
the this is a let's fake let's call it
what it is the EU is a right-wing
establishment right-wing pro corporate
establishment and if you're if you're
happy voting for that good for you but I
do not know how you can call yourself
left-wing by doing so and it's also it
goes back and it touches back when we go
to education and to me it's an
intellectual laziness yeah absolutely
because and we see it with the podcast
people go to me
Oh your podcast is right wing I'll go me
listen to it no no no exactly people
don't know what right and left wing
means anymore yeah that's that's the
problem I think it doesn't mean any yeah
exactly I think this is this is where we
come back to the power of what culture
what they have successfully done is to
convince people that to be on the Left
means that you are you are basically
using the
right words in a pro you know and a
diversity and all that sort of stuff and
to be on the right you you're raising
concerns about immigration or you're
saying I'm not going to use a new gender
pronouns or whatever that's not right
and left okay and and that's I think
that's the problem is that they've
successfully changed the meaning of
right and left and that's why you can
suddenly call me right-wing even though
my values don't seem to match that
description let me ask you this I hope
you don't mind me asking we had you on
the show you're one of our first guests
right yeah we were very happy to have
you on and I remember you were how can I
put it you were less on edge then than
you are now then you I see more on it
yes you do Wow and I wonder whether you
you're feeling the pressure of people
coming after you with Jonathan pie and
everything you're doing there and
unleash you you're having people attack
you more and therefore you feel like you
have to defend yourself more yeah
probably I think I've I'm not as active
on Twitter as I used to be because most
times I go on I'm getting someone
calling me a Nazi or all right awesome
some nonsense like that and it's so far
off I mean you know I'm not just not a
Nazi I'm auntie that I opposed that with
every fiber of my being so it's bizarre
that you you you get you get called that
you know it's really written people are
just a it's because I've spiked and they
say spiked is an alright sigh alright
means white nationalist that's what it
means you will never find a racist
statement on us on a spiked article
because just editorially they wouldn't
have it it's in not race it's an anti
racist also by the way of all the
publication's spiked has been the one
that's been most vocally opponent as
opposed the old right more than anyone
else more consistently than anyone else
has consistently opposed Donald Trump
has no no time for this so this is the
problem is these the misrepresentation
and it's people who don't read they
don't read the things they're
criticizing so let's talk about that
because I should there so just to say
yeah I apply seem on edge and everything
maybe it's just that this week I've had
a lot of this a lot this this these
people kinda be far-right extremists and
some threat a very close friend of mine
shouting at me calling me a Nazi you
know in a public place and you just
think do you know at what point I mean
do do you really believe that about me
dude you do you really believe I'm I'm
I'm that evil that's quite upset
it's distressing I agree so this is what
I was gonna ask to come back to an issue
of principle and we talked the first
time you were here and then we talked to
Brandon O'Neil who who's the editor
spiked about the restrictions around
libel and smearing people and things
like that and you know Brendon said I'm
absolutely so we don't need libel laws
we don't need this and you know after
someone like with you and with me people
calling you a Nazi because you you
refused to sign in behavioral agreement
contract or whatever you kind of go yeah
maybe we do need some libel laws do you
know what I mean yeah I mean I don't
know we're a fully stand on the law I
think we do I think I think a libel laws
make some sort of sense to me because of
course if you are saying something that
is factually wrong about someone in
order to damage their career then or
maybe what it should be is that you
pursue that through civil means and that
you know it's a legal issue in that way
you take out a civil lawsuit and there
rather than get the state involved to be
honest I don't know where I stand on
that entirely I need to give it more
thought before I come up with what I
think but I would say yeah I mean people
who are calling me for extreme is that
they're lucky I'm not litigious you know
because they'd have to demonstrate that
and and they won't be able to because
it's not true but it's also as well do
the rise of social media where everybody
has access to a voice
everybody can post whatever it is that
they want whereas before you know I mean
the the closest that we had to
criticizing people was points of view
yeah for Dan Robinson yeah absolutely I
mean which was a great program I loved
it yeah yeah bring it back yeah I mean
you know you had to write your letter
yet to post it yeah yeah it's a way to
see if you made it through whereas now
you just go online BAM not see there you
go yeah yeah it's sad isn't it but then
there's a lot of good things about
social media as well you know I mean I
wish I could get off it in a way I'm not
I sort of rely on it for work you know
that's so much my my job is on is on the
internet now so you know that's just the
way to do yeah you're absolutely right
it's ER
it people have always had these views
and have always had these limited
understandings of politics and and been
very opinionated it's amazing it's
vibrant people are opinionated but they
don't know what they're talking about
that's what you're seeing when you see
this online and this inability to listen
or to even accept that they might be
wrong about something people because it
becomes about an ego thing doesn't it
when you're online and you're having an
argument with someone there's an
awareness that everyone can
and then it becomes about scoring points
it's about locking horns it's a very
primal thing you don't want to be shown
up you don't wanna lose the argument you
don't want about you don't want to end
it at any point say oh actually might
have a point about that because that's
perceived as weakness and and and you
might look like the weaker party in that
in that in that fight and that's and
that's why sometimes online when people
are really wanting picking a fight I'll
say look let's DM let's do this over
because then the ego that because I
would be at risk as well you know I'm
I'm you know I'm not bereft of an ego I
I'm I'm aware that in those kind of
public forums even in a debate of sit
former I'm aware that I'm also trying to
protect my ego and that's not helpful
for the bay and you've got to be aware
of it and you've got to counter it and I
don't think online that's that's why
online debates are useless yeah but also
television to vote so yeah absolutely
because I find question time unwatchable
a lot of them it just descends well to
shout well what I mean I did a show two
days ago
iandale show on there yeah and it's
called cross question and and what was
great so there was me Charles Fraser
Tom ocean know his name time
conservative MP
terrible he's really nice as well and
James an economy his surname either but
he was a part of the people's vote we
what was lovely that there was a really
nice bunch on that panel I mean I
couldn't disagree with James more over
about the brexit vote and Tom believes
in pushing through Theresa mazes
checkers deal which I don't and you know
and we all had different views and we
went out for a drink afterwards it was
really great we were able to talk about
this stuff without anyone getting
insulted and getting on and it was
really refreshing it's like this is what
it should be you know but I can say I'm
Pro brexit without someone just calling
me a racist brilliant that that's a real
step forward and I would love that to be
the case that we could that we could
have that in in old restore that to
political discourse generally but we we
can't while people are slaves to this
cultish world view and while they are
buying into the fantasy of the rise of
neo-nazism within Britain and they think
that Nazis are everywhere and they and
they just assume that you have these
malevolent intentions we won't be able
to that's why the culture war is
actually really important because we
can't make any other games politically
socially economically and
this stuff is sorted out because no
one's listening to each other anymore
they're just insulting each other it
comes to a point where to me a debate is
where two people discuss something and
then they go away and I'll have a think
about it yeah that's what it should be
or to be open to the possibility that
you're wrong
yeah right and the and this thing about
you know I mean my I'd say my core
principles have always been consistent
but my views on various things have been
refined and nuanced and changed on the
basis of talking to people and hearing
other views right and that's all that's
how it should be if you if you go into
an argument with the belief that your
opponent is evil you know
it is it has a really dark sinister evil
agenda secret agenda some clandestine
Machiavellian worldview what can you
learn from that person nothing because
you've already put up the brick wall
nothing's going to happen and and and
and your your views will become more
entrenched and that's where you get
that's where you get this cultish
mindset it just reminds me of george w
bush when he said if God is on our side
how can we be wrong yeah yeah it is it's
religious I'm always very wary of the
irrational you know and I'm whereof it
in myself as well you know that we all
have that capacity and I that's why I
think it's about education I think once
we once we restore that in schools then
then things will slowly change it's
gonna take a while I think we'll get
worse before gets better I think also
the understanding of the importance of
truth yeah over feelings and over mood
and over whatever the the the social the
socially acceptable thing is do you
think and to know is important because
you know like for growing up in the
Soviet Union I grew up in a society
which was maintained yeah by not
allowing people to speak the truth yeah
because the system was so flawed he was
so corrupt it was so unfounded in the
way that it was designed that one person
speaking the truth about it in public
was enough to collapse it yeah right and
what I sense with this with this work
ideology and and the institutions that
they've created is they have to suppress
the truth or they feel like
they do they have to suppress the truth
because someone telling the truth in
public about their system and about
their way of thinking would collapse the
system because it doesn't make sense
yeah it's not logically sound it's not
coherent and it's not based on the fact
whether it's the gender pay gap
whether it's is institutional racism all
of the stuff that with the narrative is
one thing and the truth is something
completely different they can't afford
to to surrender that high ground can
they I mean the gender pay gaps a good
example and when we did the video about
it for Jonathan PI and so many angry
critiques of that but nobody actually
engaging with any of the arguments that
never happens you know and and that's
erm it's a shame you know because I'll
be willing to have that debate well
since we had you on and you talked about
that we've had dozens of economists and
other experts come and basically
explained that it's like 90% nothing to
do with discrimination about people's
choices it's about the careers they
choose but you dough to facts yeah you
see this is about it and if the facts
are inconvenient then the the tendency
seems to be to just avoid them or not
debate them or just dismiss the
opponents you know and it's because the
ideology of the woke ideology is is self
discrediting it is internally incoherent
you know if you say that gender is a
social construct
except for trans people who are born
with a male brain or female brain that's
a biological essentialist position right
so you can't have both you can't have
both so there's there is this this
problem that it as an ideology it is
messed up it doesn't work and it will
collapse but it just depends when it's
going to collapse and it and that's why
they're putting up all these barricades
and that's why they attack people so
vehemently that's why they push for
censorship that's why they oppose free
speech because they know that with
speech debate and discussion bad ideas
fall yeah and they're back there but I
there they've got women are one of the
worst ideas in the world and that will
that will crumble under scrutiny so they
have to suppress the debate well the
only people who fear truth of people who
are peddling lives
yeah well it's are their lies which I
suspect might be the case with some
people do I also think people do
genuinely believe it in the way that you
know the the the the people who worship
Baal or whatever believe and you know
they they do
yeah I don't think it's insincere in a
lot of the case I'm the thing since and
I think they've bought a life they've
bought yeah they have here and so I
don't know how we do it I don't know how
we move beyond it other than keep keep
challenging as far as you can and accept
that those in power will try and stop
you if you were going to make
predictions I know it's always difficult
to make predictions but why not we're at
this this is yeah I always get it wrong
yeah I guess you know you know this way
at the very beginning of January its
2019 yeah where do you think this is
gonna go over the coming year so I think
every new year I think oh well there's
been so many ridiculous stories in the
present so much you know this isn't
political correctness by the way that I
think one of the reasons why we're not
advancing this debate and why they keep
doubling down is because of course back
in the 90s right you had these stupid
[ __ ] stories like winterville oh you
know they're trying to ban Christmas now
which wasn't the case it was berming the
City Council who would come up with this
phrase winterville to encapsulate all
the various festive traditions right
that no one's trying to ban Christmas or
saying but that's the way it was
reported by reactionary right-wing
tabloids then you had the bar bar
rainbow sheep you remember that one that
was front page of the Express you're no
longer allowed to say black in nursery
schools this nursery school is doing all
it was was that this nursery teacher was
teaching kids about the colors of the
rainbow and it changed the song in order
to do so with nothing to do with right
so therefore you had all this stuff and
all these awful people our political
correctness has gone mad and you had all
this kind of reactionary you know kind
of Richard a little John thing right and
that's why when we point out that things
are going too far now the the common
response is oh you're just part of this
PC gone mad brigade you're you they they
are comparing us to Richard little John
this is not political correctness this
is something far more sinister
all right political correctness is a
good idea political correctness is about
the social discourse and negotiating the
social discourse and trying to have a
mutually agreed way that we talk to each
other in public politeness etiquette
that's what it is which I'm all for
right I'm not all for locking people
away for what they say if they breach
those those terms but I think we do have
a social contract don't we
but that's not what's going on now this
isn't political correctness I don't use
that term but you'll know if your emails
because I don't I don't attack political
correctness because I don't see this
woke movement as political correctness
and that's the problem that's why things
aren't changing because in the mindset
of the woke community we are just too
rich and Littlejohn's we're the same
it's the same fight it's not in a whole
new vowel and the end and we need a new
language for it and actually in that
sense I'd rather like the
anti-authoritarian on my side too to
stop using that phrase political
correctness cuz I think it muddies the
waters is unhelpful so I think in terms
of the prediction until we find the new
lexicon to deal with this phenomenon
whatever it is whatever we want to call
it there's new dogmatism political
dogmatism maybe I don't know then then
we'll get nowhere and people will keep
doubling down and they'll keep using
every strategy they can to push this
ideology and I think it will get a lot
worse but because like you say most
people recognize this for the [ __ ]
that it is most normal people
it won't survive ultimately when
survival take a long time of it I don't
know I don't know about that I think
you're being pessimistic
honestly like I alright you have some
jokes where you talk about the fact that
if you don't mind me quoting one of your
jokes you'll mess it up when you yeah I
would definitely by the time but then if
you tell the joke you will look even
worse especially in this format exactly
what was the joke which is the joke
about how the term naughty has a very
specific meaning yeah and you talk about
its combat 18 it's whatever
yeah it's Mumsnet is the punchline right
yeah okay so while my situation was
happening with this behavioral agreement
contract yeah a friend of mine went on
the Mumsnet radical feminist forum
that's already funny right and sent me a
screenshot of what they were discussing
yeah and the radical feminist on Mumsnet
were all on my side right okay there you
go so if if they're on our side then I
really my sense is there's a sliver of
this world mentality somewhere that's
got power but the rest of society is
just waiting for people like us to stand
up in overturn
maybe I wouldn't use Mumsnet as a gauge
for the future maybe yeah I mean people
you know most people and people this is
the other thing like so many I mean the
thing about the comedy establishment is
they've all gone they they're thinking
in terms of careers and I get that right
so they are on board with the woke thing
because that's the way the
establishments pushing it but you know
when you talk to comics in private oh
yeah they'll tell you yes they know most
of them do anyway and but they do it
when they're a bit drunk or they're
confiding in you that you know they they
wouldn't tweet about it in the way that
I do and yeah and part of the reason I
do is because you know I don't feel like
I've got anything to lose in that score
anymore I was never gonna be televisual
or you know it so I just sort of I just
say what I think now and also I think
it's more it's really liberating isn't
it just to be honest yeah Oh massively
like I really feel for all those people
who who do sort of have these opinions
like the people who do oppose this
creeping authoritarianism and they want
to say more about it but they know that
if they do that they're scoring their
chances of a lucrative career I get that
you know it's it's it's difficult but
surely isn't that the antithesis of what
comedy should be you think about the
great comedians they're the ones who
call out what they perceive to be you
know the inaccuracies of falsity they're
the ones we fall in love with they're
the ones that we quote endlessly there's
a reason why people love Bill Hicks yeah
yeah but I mean he wouldn't do so well
today with you oh you know yeah
absolutely I think so I'm more
optimistic than you are but you're right
it's liberating I mean last time we
talked I remember you saying you'd come
to a point in your career and you just
said I'm not going to be mealy-mouthed
about what I think yeah and it's been
what eight nine months and now I'm in
that position I've come to that point as
well with this contract I was kind of
forced in yeah yeah they forced a hand
they forced my hand yeah because I it
went viral without any intention on my
part yeah but once it happened but then
they'll say that you were well I know I
saw the accusation yeah I mean you would
cynically manipulate yes yeah it's that
thing of they can't bear the idea that
someone has sincerely held beliefs that
don't match their own odd odd idea yeah
and the funny thing to me is they just
they think they think that publicity is
generated by you like calling up a news
paper and going yeah hey I've got this
opinion put me on TV yeah yeah and it's
like if I could do that do you not think
I would be doing that every day I'd be
having a viral story out there every day
all day for the rest of my life and what
they don't seem to get is this story
with me had nothing to do with comedy it
was just like the reason it went viral
is that 95% of the population look at it
and go I am censoring myself in my own
life yeah and I see comedy as just a way
of reflecting my own experience and that
and I think that's why I think this is
going to be a well we'll see a year from
now we'll have you back here we come
back next year and you'll be like told
you it's going to be shared constant in
and I'll be like yeah I know my new
studio we might be all great it might be
all rosy next year you know well that's
my sense of it man I thought I genuinely
think with what you're doing with comedy
I'm least having played about two or
three times now and you know Francis
will be there and you've got a bunch of
other great comedians coming I'd just
sense that the tide is turning yeah yeah
maybe I mean I know the clip of you
reading out the behavioral agreement
form at comedy Unleashed was online and
you hear people jeering at the idea of
and I've seen that in the press being
misinterpreted as oh these people are
jeering at the idea of being nice to
people though then are and and and and
you must know they're not but they're
jeering at the concept of trying to
please comedy and you know that's what
the joke is but if you're gonna
willfully misinterpret that to make a
political point then that's that's what
we're fighting against really I if I eat
I should urge the people to watch that
clip I think it's really interesting
what it isn't there was a group of
racists saying oh my god why can't we be
racist anymore you had that accusation
didn't you though yeah they liked that
you obviously want the right to stand up
on stage I don't talk about the person
who wrote that story just because I
don't want to give them any more public
fair enough okay okay then they
shouldn't get in the first place but but
but the point the point I'm making - yet
there were people who came after me
almost exclusively comedians actually
that's not you know almost comedians
it's almost like they just did it in
order to bring attention to themselves
and further their career I stopped into
eating motive
would never happen but he but like I say
I just felt like the support from
ordinary people for what happened was so
strong yeah that I feel like that it's
just wait the people ordinary people are
just waiting for someone to stand up
this is a head above it this is such a
disconnect isn't there between it
between the people with the power and
them and them not normal people and that
goes for comedy goes for politics right
I mean you at the moment we have got our
Parliament trying to completely thought
the wishes of the electorate this is
insane you know and and they're doing it
with these seriously Orwellian terms
like people's vote like we are doing
this to be more democratic we want more
democracy so we're going to ignore your
referendum right what is going on I mean
this is they don't understand how
damaging this is going to be to
democracy when I mean I don't think
brexit will happen now and I think that
I think there's a complete naivety
amongst the political class when it
comes to this issue
they won't the public might forgive this
this isn't this is incredible you know
parliamentary democracy is a good system
right it's there as a kind of conduit to
what we can make things happen right
some of the people can make things
happen to make their wishes be served in
an in a political context right what
parliamentary democracy isn't is we vote
someone in so that they can ignore what
we want and that's what's happening
right so I don't know I think I think
the legacy of this of this brexit issue
is going to be a big okay I tried to I
tried to end the show in a positive yes
very hard so why don't we do the last
question cuz well well we are out of
time well the last question is what's
the one thing that we're not talking
about that we should talk about but I
think you sort of touched upon it with
the bricks yeah I think so yeah and I'm
sorry see they're both [ __ ] doing it
I was trying to be positive this is the
first episode of trigonometry season two
I could it's a bad joke we're all [ __ ]
haha but what do you think let's again
dangerous predictions right okay do you
think if we don't go through with it
if we don't honor the agreement yeah
what do you think it's gonna happen okay
we go but let's try me light though
let's try and be like okay the funny
side of this is that it is
essentially funny our Democratic
representatives hate democracy it's
really funny and we know that they look
the EU has a record at traitor they
think they put out these referendums
right and then they just say now you got
the wrong answer let's do it again
why don't they do that one with the knee
and Lisbon yeah Denmark on the
Maastricht Treaty and the Greece and the
austerity measures now with it
we'll have the referendum we'll put on
the show that you know you you know you
can have your opinion little people you
know will have the plebiscite and then
we'll just will screw you over because
we know better we know best working
classes they need to just stick to their
place right and there is something quite
hilarious about that I also love the
amnesia about always just an advisory
referendum this is hilarious stuff right
nobody knew they were voting to leave
the single market right but what is so
funny about this is there's a thing
called the internet and you and you can
go back and you can look at every major
debate in which it was absolutely
explicitly clear that we were going to
leave the single market hey you know the
Wembley Arena the biggest televised
debate with David David Dimbleby the
first section of that right on it on the
economy
there was a video out lying what are the
repercussions of leaving the single
market and it is there on YouTube takes
you to minutes mate right it's a bit
this incredible thing now no one knew
what they were voting for no one knew
they'd vote it because of something on
the side of a bus are you kidding me do
you think people have that stupid they
voted because they saw something on a
bus a bus told me how to vote what you
do know you may as well say that people
voted remain because because Cameron
said that Isis would vote leave right so
me which he did he said he said anyone
said he was gonna bricks it would kick
off World War three these are this is
funny [ __ ] I mean it is it is
essentially funny right and and we have
to acknowledge that the idea that people
didn't know the idea that people didn't
know about the single market that's
great everyone said it Cameron Osbourne
everyone on both sides said it and then
saying that the advert it was advisory
by the way the government sent out a
leaflet they spent 10 million pounds
sending a leaflet to every single house
outlying
their argument for remaining in the EU
which was predicated on the membership
of the common of the single market the
customs union right and then they said
but you didn't know you sent out a
[ __ ] pamphlet right and then you
wrote the words this is your decision
the government will implement
what you decide but it was advisory
really without typo this is funny so
there's loads of room for comedy in this
and we should that's what we should be
doing in order to try and make the
changes that we need to make I mean this
is a seismic change but people you know
that people are conservative essentially
they don't want things to change this is
a massive change and they come up with
all these economic predictions we're
gonna be we're gonna crash out they keep
saying that crash we're crashing out
with no deal it's it's well trade rules
mate it's fine you know you if you know
anything about the history of economics
you know that economic predictions are
always wrong Bank of England got it
wrong with the their predictions about
what would happen after the vote they've
got it so wrong they had to apologize
right so it's a major opportunity
leaving the EU it's a huge opportunity
in terms of world trade and the EU is a
sinking ship anyway it's breaking apart
it's gonna died like we getting out
first as already is a really good thing
to do but we didn't embrace it as an
opportunity our government saw it as
damage limitation and that's why they
weren't able to negotiate a sufficient
deal they weren't able to do it you
can't negotiate a deal that you don't
believe in the majority of MPs on both
sides of the house on labour and Tory
are remain as and they think they know
best and they will find a way to to
thwart the will of the people right and
I hate that phrase but it is exactly
what it is that's what democracy means
that's what the origin of the word means
right we've made that they outsource the
decision but they didn't like the result
and now they're trying to find a way
through with a small print right it's
funny alright let's end the show by
telling Andrew that we both were to
remain yeah yeah because we're good
people yeah [ __ ] I every time he does
that joke we got like hundreds of
messages can I call you a Nazi now
position yeah all right okay so guys
this has been the first episode of our
show you will see that next week when we
release our second episode we are gonna
talk about that being the first episode
that's because we didn't know which one
was going to be first but this is going
to be the first one so ignore all that
[ __ ] and the other one
Andrew Doyle is on Twitter at Andrew
Doyle underscore calm yes a go there
call him an RT he likes that
join the club join the club everyone
else is doing it right they might as
well get it and comes comedy unleash
absolutely come to comedy Unleashed I've
been there Francis is going to be
performing there a few really really
funny people are going to be there over
the next few months it's a great place
it's a great place to meet like-minded
people as well so come along it's
absolutely fantastic and like I said I
think it's the start of a new thing in
comedy and you'll want to be there
you'll want to tell your grandchildren
you were there when it happened
so come along thank you very much for
coming on the show Andre thank you
and as always follow us on Twitter on
Facebook on Instagram we're going to be
talking about stuff that's happening
with patron and with other ways of
supporting the show because that's gone
a bit haywire in later episodes or in a
separate clip so keep an eye out for
that thank you very much for supporting
us as always and we will see you next
week take care guys see you later bye
bye thanks very much
[Music]
[Music]